what makes a great storyteller hmm I
think what makes a great storyteller is
someone who is open to the collaborative
process open to knowing that as we're
taught when we're little two heads are
better than one
but for whatever reason we come we
become adults and we want to do
everything by ourselves so I think great
storytellers understand their part of
the process they understand that other
people can bring stuff to the process
they're open to utilizing what's
happening in the world around them so
for example I traveled for a decade as
the touring artist I was always in
different places so that means I've met
different kinds of people I saw
different kind of places and we never
really pay attention to the fact that
because I was in that area or around
those people I probably picked up on
some new information so we're always
told to write what we know and that
automatically becomes so narrow to us
when we think about well how can I know
but it's like if you consider the places
that you've been the people that you've
met what your spouse may do for a living
whether your parents may have done for a
living what your friends may be doing
what they may be going through in their
personal lives if you were a child and
you watched how mom and dad did X Y & Z
all of these things are things that you
know and therefore things that you can
write about so you just have to be open
storytellers have to be open to notes
that's a I think we all know as artists
you have to be open to criticism but
criticism is different from notes and a
lot of the times writers aren't able to
tell the difference they're thinking the
executives are coming in here to steal
my joy okay you know into the rain on my
parade and really they're coming in with
a totally different part of the process
they are coming in from a totally
different spectrum to look at your
script and nine times out of ten if they
have a note all that means is there's a
problem here you can decide to fix it in
any creative way sometimes they will
tell you no this is what it has to be
and that's usually because again they're
coming from a different place they may
know something about the location that
you don't know let me know something
about permits that you don't know they
may know something about the actors that
you don't know they may have information
that again if they're pushing towards
their brand
and whatever it is that you're writing
now seems to be taking them out of that
brand then they're gonna be saying
alright nope let's take this outlet you
know do this or do that
but I think as creatives we will then
take that personally and think that
that's criticism instead of
understanding they're doing their part
on the team you're doing your part on
the team so don't take it personally or
negatively just realize that they're
coming in it coming into the situation
from a different perspective so
storytellers have to be open to that too
so as much as we have to respect the art
we also have to understand that there's
a business side of the art and a lot of
the times that means you may have to
compromise your art to the people who
are paying for it which again goes back
to that whole baby thing right like the
point of view writing it is so that
other people can see it the only way
other people are gonna see it unless you
have your own money because if someone
else buys it and once they buy it it's
now theirs so they're the ones who get
to say when what direction it goes into
and what schools it's gonna go to and
all these other things right where you
consider your child so just being open
to understanding as a storyteller that
there is an art side and there is a
business side I think that's really big
have you seen someone who has such
amazing talent as a writer but the notes
process ruin their career because they
were never able to be collaborative yes
but I think it probably happens more
often than we really know being a being
on a writing staff means that a you're
on the staff right now but B you have to
wait to see if the show is gonna get
picked get picked back up if it does it
doesn't mean that girl automatically
picked back up and one of the ways that
you cannot get picked back up is you
don't take notes well right so some
people are often not getting picked back
up on the next season simply because
they couldn't take notes well and again
especially if you're on a staff you're
here to write someone else's baby
so your opinion matters but you writing
what you're being asked to write matters
more right so there are there are people
who just need it's like a learning curve
for them so I
necessarily say that they never worked
again maybe they learned from that and
they were able to work again there have
also been times when people in authority
are kind of mismanaging how they're
doing the writing by attaching
themselves to someone else's writing in
that kind of room process without
realizing that the writer is doing the
writing just because you're giving notes
on the writing doesn't make you a writer
and so a lot of the times depending upon
where their producers are show runners
or directors or whatever it is that they
are they may be getting confused in that
part of the process and now they attach
themselves to the writing and I know
that there have been people who have
lost their jobs because of things like
that as well simply because that's what
their job is this is what your job is
just because they work together doesn't
mean that they're now teams or coal
writers or you know coal whatever so
that can happen as well but that again
goes back to people not really
understanding how that part of the
industry works and some people have to
learn by trial and error and it happens
that way oh okay so I yeah I didn't know
that I never would have thought of that
so it's not just the writer possibly
getting hung up on these notes it's also
the note giver not realizing their role
it's their role as well it's like you're
the no Giver
that's a part of your responsibility
that doesn't make you a writer because
no givers may also give suggestions
right and so now they're thinking well I
gave XY and Z suggestions so now it's
you and I who have written this thing it
was like no writers are the ones who are
physically writing right if you are a
producer a showrunner or a director when
it comes to features right you may be
adding possibly but if you're not doing
and the WGA has rules about if you
didn't do it a particular percentage I'm
not gonna try to figure out remember
what the percentage was but if you did
do a percentage of the physical writing
and cannot put your name on as a writer
now in features things are gonna be a
little different anyway because the
writer is taken out so early in the
process right so there could be other
people who have come in and actually
done more writing and there's still a
percentage of writing that they have to
do before their name gets attached but
there's a difference in how there
gets attached it might say if you see
the word a in D then that means this was
an extra person who got attached if you
see the ampersand sign that means
they're a team that means they wrote it
together me and this person wrote this
script together if you see the word and
it means they wrote it and then somebody
else came in and put their part and
somebody else came in and put their part
so you might see one person's name and
then 50 other ends you know because all
of these other people came in and they
put in enough of a percentage for them
to be getting a credit some people who
are rewriters are simply ghost writers
and they never get a credit but they
might have come in and done some writing
but then once that writing process is
over and now that script is in the hand
of the director he's gonna hear she is
gonna go in and change up all kinds of
stuff doesn't make him or her the writer
so you're rarely going to see suddenly
just because now that the development is
over in his introduction and the
director is now doing things with the
script it's not gonna necessarily now
throw his or her name on there because
he or she is doing what what he or she
has to do in order to make the
production happen and they may be making
a lot of different creative you know
suggestions and creative changes but it
doesn't make them the writer so again
stay in your last day and you're laying
back you got to know what your lane is
and stay in it
you